[Music]
it's a harsh world strong prayer in the
week down here gotta stay focused on
your dream
what's your dream I'll show you
[Music]
[Music]
this is my secret place best view in
town
really cool no look Daffy you
right
I wonder what it's like up there better
than this dump down here
listen stuff from the factory pulling up
the song
but the tubes are just for cargo not for
people if I was as strong as you I climb
that tube dissol him right now
hey don't let anybody up there that's
what they want you to think you just
gotta know the right people I happen to
be connected Oh that'll be willing to do
what it takes
wherever it takes
fine thing is you've seen it you just
can't remember what do you mean doc
found you in the scrapyard all that
stuff is dumped from zahlen so you must
be from up there
I guess so if you could just tell me
what those eyes have seen I wish I could
I keep trying to remember but it's still
a blank starting to feel like I wasn't
very important just an insignificant
girl thrown out with the rest of the
garbage
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's a truck we're looking for me doctor
should I say hunter-warrior
hunter-warrior oh no looks like he's God
hey hey
thanks for bringing a girl that's gonna
stay with some time
[Music]
nice boy
you came to rescue me that is so you
have nice eyes he's mine you can have
the girl
so long as I get his eyes no need to run
[Music]
rip that plea
[Music]
you are so beautiful I want to rip you
open and see if you're ugly inside like
the others
[Music]
watch her tie
[Music]
Jameer little flea so I can pinch your
head off
[Music]
[Music]
you'll pay wants me guru Mexican does
not forget I'm coming for you both
[Music]
[Music]
well look at you may your dreams bring
you peace this is just this is not bad
or good that part's up to you
I don't mean to be rude I supposed to
know you actually me we just met
of the
beep
it's harsh world strong prey on the weak
down here
yes
does it bother you that I'm not
completely human
whatever I had to you for you I give you
whatever I have I give you my heart
Alida they will come for you
why
I think you're someone very special me
stay here
of the
[Music]
[Music]